اطرش وزيسكو سيستيدي
كانوا حضور الشرطه والصحافيين اكبر من
المشاركين فيه وعلى خطى زعماء اليمين
المتطر في اوروبا الذين يستخدمون العداء
للاسلامي ولمهاجرين المسلمين ورقه ربحه
لكسب الشعبيه اقدم رسم سبالودان وهو ناشط
سياسي دنماركي سويدي المغمور لكنه معروف
بمعاداته لمهاجرين على حرق نسخه من القران
الكريم تحت انظاري وحمايه الشرطه
اثار تساؤلات بشان سماح السويد بعمل
استفزازي واسع النطاق تعتبره دول كثيره
جريمه كراهيه
قد حصل على تصريح بتنظيم المظاهره امام
السفاره التركيه في ستوكهولم وسمحت الشرطه
بتنظيمها التزام بقوانين البلاد التي تقفل
حريه التعبير عن الراي ونشر الافكار بغد
النظر عنف احواها
وبينما وصف بعض سلوك بلودان بانه عبسي و
فردي لان بعض الاخر اعتبر ان للفعل مارب
السياسيه
بسم الله الله اكبر
على تنظيم مظاهرات في مدن سويديه باحياء
تقتل فيها اعداد كبيره من المسلمين وعاده
المكان تتحلل تلك المظاهرات عمليه حرق نسخ
من المصحف لاستفزاز مشاعرهم وتصوير الامر
وكانه يتعلق بمساله حريه التعبير اعتقادا
من بالوذن بانه سيثير الراي العام السويدي
ضد المسلمين في البلاد فهو ينتمي الى حزب
يطالب بترحيل المسلمين
وينظر الى الاسلام والمسلمين على انه ما
يمثلان مشكله كبيره
ويعتزم حول الانتخابات المجمعه في سبتمبر
المقبل وهو ما دفع مراقبين للقول انه
يستخدم ملف العداء للمسلمين ورقه رابحه في
مساعه لزياده شعبيه في الشارع والفوز
بالانتخابات
اثار جدلا كبيرا بشان حدود حريه التعبير
وماذا كان يجب ان تكون هذه الحريه بلا
قيود وما هو السبيل الامثل مواجهه اعتداء
اي جماعه سياسيه او دينيه على مقدسات
الاخرين وازدرائها ولا يبدو ان هذا الجدل
سيختفي قريبا فحرقوا مصحف صغير يؤدي في
الغالب الى حرائق اكبر